merci dit là et pino jeudi à catherine
des cyclopes hyundai temps seulement à
peine ou des batch et à thématique là
puisque l'on cassotti de santiago des
coups bas mais sidy là mais si mais si
des invités mais maurice aussi dit
l'actrice l'alliance française en ville
santiago des coups bas parce que faut
préciser la même pas côté de shibani des
alliances françaises qui en alliant
c'est ce qu'a fait alors on et alliances
françaises chargées de fait la promotion
des langues et cultures france est donc
le café la promotion français parce
qu'on attend d'un pays ac a accueilli
nounou kabako de france est belle et la
clé à prendre français et puis nos
gammes promouvoir la culture française
en parce que le camp organisé des
actions nukafu ni des artistes nous café
des expositions de dada de photos
sculptures peintures bas et qu'on s'a
daddy artistes français et puis
francophones et paye actuellement
draconides yann française attaquent pas
exactement c'est pas si vous laissez pas
taipei à café qu' il n'y plusieurs
alliances et poids français un point
culture française à adam p -b surtout en
ville de santiago on y sera bien
particulier puis 23 16 20 et puisque
santiago pas si loin qu'il soit dix pays
haïti exactement justement par rapport à
proximité talent est là jay dépendance
haïti fait ni en lots colons français
qui quitte ea qui fut haïti pour
installer adam prouve un stade province
que lorientais qui c'est
et puis santiago c'est capital lit donc
tout l'écolo français tavini épi
savoir-faire fériau et celio qui
introduit la culture du café attaque par
exemple pas réussi et puis aux vignes et
et puis esclaves haïtiens et au dos et
booth a connu une langue français
important pas côté talent et aux
cantonales aux coyotes n'ont toujours
pas quitté santiago
oui parce que nyon tall haïtien qu'à
continuer vinyle a donc ni empile
nagnakalé montréal est est ce que c'est
descendant de haïti à orrville santiago
jeudi à cavigny aux autres pour
apprendre à les français par exemple
exactement par exemple munis des
étudiants en médecine qui est ce que la
fac de médecine n'a qu'une hâte à cuba
cavignaux elle nous fournit à la fois
des cours de français puisque une cape à
lillebonne france aimez ou pas jake a
écrit et puis hop hajek à maîtriser
grammaire là mais aussi pour need des
cours d'espagnol parce que ces mêmes
baila yucca pas les espagnols mais
grammaire là c'est pas eu parfois mon
pléiade en grammaire là alors l'alliance
française c'est une occasion de faire
promotion tout ça qui cultivent
française ce qu'à travail
et puis d'étudiants maison par l'école
pour à proprement dit non nous parler
comme nous c'est enfin nous pend
établissements scolaires nous c'est en
sorte de langue donc le nid des
étudiants mais les étudiants ni de 7 à
77 ans et tout le monde qu'il est à
apprendre le français cabinet pas ni
l'âge et les ces montants du tavini
oiseaux tu y aucun pays et l'agent pouce
à ces débats qui subventionné par le
gouvernement français avec monaco ça va
passer alors effectivement ni entente
entre cuba et puis la france parce que
d'autres savent que la vie à rennes
tibhrine cuba donc les moulins pagnol où
l'agent donc lui aubameyang luna gens
donc nou ka mandé aux antilles lan
monnet par exemple puyo faire un
semestre pour apprendre français
notamment des eaux entre deux et puis
l'équivalent de entre 2 puis 5 euros
c'est qui c'est comme ma pile là jean
paul simon mailloux beurre saccadé
pandémie mais c'est un rebelle l'agent
quand même alors catherine décidé à
pousser nos matinik oui où commença dans
l'éducation nationale
brusquement bande passante est tout
envie rentrer dedans tous égaux crier
coopération internationale au sens
expatriés tout simplement mais qui
maniait au river apostats parce qu'on
savait avant tout à fait coopération
internationale organisme international
dans l'omc a demandé de manière
localisée vrai oui ça avait son caddie
malade alors profil moins intéressés
le ministère des affaires étrangères
parce que h&m en six mois c'est ballot
ministère des affaires étrangères au
colloque un travail parce que à la base
mon fait l'étude de longmont ces
prophéties pagnol à la base et puis
après mon patient concours pour divine
et chefs d'établissement donc majorité
s'est empressé d'y espagnol a pris mon
fait c'est ton comme chef
d'établissement scolaire et celle en
état montre comment postuler coûtera
paix en détachement dans la coopération
de mon café coopération culturelle pas
encore plus réuni plusieurs types
coopération nous là pour match et la
présence française à dents à dans le
monde 1 et - branches - ses influences
culturelles jour oui mais non
moratti topal et les salons ou entrer à
têtu était chiba et je dis enfin rentré
il ya bon matin là cailloux à thématique
a estimé que hausse en matinée chez sk
travail sincère ou des coups bas et ont
envie mais teplice passerelle au petit
il est noir et pis ce compris la grande
île de la caraïbe exactement parce que
justement - là comme le disait tout pour
vous et la france est bien tiré la
france et ki moon qui piquent pas qu'ils
font c'est qu'ils prennent cuba comme
anthony quessy guadeloupe donc moi c'est
lui demander ni compter évidemment vie
que la martinique à launay et que
martinique doit présenter la france
atteint cuba et qui veut dire croyez ça
où l'on vit ni passeport comme et on
pourrait ici à mon bureau tous ces
artistes noirs par exemple tout ça qui
organise pour tirer le podium on essaie
fabas gagne avant de profiter de
structures toilées catherine l'alliance
française exactement parce que voilà
pour des hutus bâillements là pour
organiser
l'allant et culturel 2017 et pour pour
organiser pour programmes offerts
programmation culturelle 2017 mans les
mettez martinique et pianiste
martiniquais à lou née voilà donc c'est
pour ça moi la manquer on compte manqué
ou à tout aliment ni des rendez vous le
dimanche km en 4 h iia dans la culture
l'éducation etc
et c'est ça mon limité à l'onema j'anime
café ça ni par les autres associations
matinée chiba peut-être assouplissant
d'orientation politique mais on dit par
exemple à granville qu'on l'en matin qui
jumelé pis interviews des coups bas
placé vu passer en bêta demandé
exactement six exactement l'état s'était
20e on est jeune âge là d'ailleurs mon
amant savent que ni en délégation
lamentin qui y vit jodie à hâter
santiago ça dommage d'ailleurs que nous
caraty quoi nous et bike a fait anti
aussi vous voulez mais ça manque a
trouvé dommage c'est que justement niang
représentation la france at-elle
santiago et nous pas qu'à essayer
associés qu on nous attaque a fait
augmenter ni képi cuba donc faut quand
même essayer institutionnaliser les
choses pour que la france savent que
leur volonté de prestige analysez vous
la fait tomber des plus fluides
oui baila fluide mais s'ils voulaient
les bains avec un fait qu'on s'a de
manière informelle et ou phoques nous
chercher que baye aletti brin plus loin
et que ça ni des rois tombé bas toute la
martinique parce que là c'est vrai
concède un deal en nous et puis l'amitié
qui fois entre lamentin et puis santiago
mais si vous voulez c'est pas tout
jeunes qui savent ça et ça m'a laissé
que ça public et que cela bénéficie à
toute la martinique qui sont repris et
qu'il tient exactement est ce que par
exemple un équipe football qui basket
khady koita tiens nous ces perles et
chiba pour gad équivalente à 80 par
exemple en matière sportif est ce que
l'alliance piraterie et en demandant la
force'' bits et en livrant pas l'entente
tableau puis c'est un très bon d'autres
états dont 20 août à nous pas figé
concernés manqua pas les deux cultures
en cap à l'est dit échanges csii on peut
apporter l'autre au rayonnement x alors
exactement et puis même nous que tout
mon cas fesses pour mise peut-être que
c'est pas même manière qu bec approuve
kako s'ouvrait ce pont est purement
think est donc ça bien que yugo couvre
nos contrées coillot pourrait changer en
les préparations objectif débats et
concerts dont bas - ça qu'a fait partie
de la culture du web
on ya l'autre lac à appréhender le même
maicon ou alors si par exemple en ce
moment mais matinik marajo mise zigbee
et mcafee pour quelque chose à mon café
un sac un témoin qui sera mon café mocha
travailleurs soit seize banques à vigny
web un 5e match et qui ça surtout on
peut penser - alors ça mon pc petit bal
c'est en contact et puis après lukaku
magnanou paix fait les choses parce que
c'est vrai que nous prochain martinique
effet cubain et seulement 3 et avions
cassé par les new york arrive exactement
mais où savent que transport entre les
différents ils la caraïbe chai donc faut
que nous trouver des moyens pour
subventionner les actions les bas est là
nous les organiser donc oui nous paie ni
envie joie nous qu'on nous fait des
bébés phoques ou trouver moyen
subventionné actions ou les mains des
questions ne repose pas ce que nous
prépare des requêtes qui décidera au
savs que aux palabres elle est politique
maintenant même cocasse senti que cuba
caffery me assous et changement de
politique locale rapprochement et puis
des états unis est ce que vous envie de
santiago où cas senti ça pour l'instant
non membres khawaja santiago loin dit la
havane santiago plis près haïti la
jamaïque république dominicaine santiago
tourné vers la caraïbe pour couvrir les
états unis donc beaucoup et catherine
ceylac acidité répond nous et puis
surtout le crédit en ont pâti privatif
et matériel médical
et bien quoi pas le crioc bien sûr aux
mathématiques et à prendre mais pas
l'espagne que si la halle lac et du beau
problème mais si les epide me rappeler
que sedin actress directrice alliances
françaises en ville santiago